the one of the stories that goes
talking about you is the fact that uh
james o'keefe has made 1.9 million
dollars since 2011 right and they show
your income okay okay and it goes from
which to me the income is four hundred
thousand dollar your income whatever it
was in 2020 or 2021 we have the exact
numbers based on the article
and it says you're one he raised it was
a small thing he raised only four
hundred thousand dollars and he has a
job where he was working 60 hours a week
or 80 hours a week making 50k year
before i think the article you've read
before and it goes he raised one million
dollars he raised two million dollars he
raised four million dollars now he's
raising eight million dollars 12 million
dollars and eventually it was a 20 i
think you raised 21 million dollars in
2020 whether it's 2020 or 2019 you raise
something like 21 million dollars right
and then in the book there's a part
where
they call you out and they say
well who are the backers
who's given the money to project veritas
there's an article that says koch
brothers there's an article that says
names that comes out about you right and
then your position was
i think it has been
a by law to not release the information
of
uh the guys the individuals who give
money to our organization you said
something like that in your book right
and i'm sure you know what i'm talking
about
so so you know
again you do you want people to know who
gives money to your organization do you
want the public to know who you give
money to the organization it's it's a
it's a
a fundamental right enshrined in the
first amendment freedom of association
so there's a distinction there in that
there's a chapter in this book called
secrecy and i talk a lot about this
there's two things there's three things
that we can keep secret and there's no
other secrets
one of those is the the donor donors to
our non-profit which by the way don't
tell us what to do
uh it's a freedom of association right
enshrined in this case uh naacp versus
alabama supreme court justice john
marshall
economic reprisals loss of employment
threat of physical coercion and
manifestations of physical hostilities
there's a quote from the united states
supreme court you do not want to
disclose
donor identities to organizations
philanthropic news organizations be
precisely because of the fear and the
intimidation and surveillance sure
quite different than
charlie chester at cnn admitting what
his actual
and what the actual uh motives and
agenda
are
um and if i was doing that people should
expose me because these people have
tremendous power
and it's their and it's their ability to
manufacture the public's consent
you know i think the informed consent in
this country is critical in the american
founding and this sort of jeffersonian
ideal of the public's right to know
which makes us much different than any
other country in the history of the
world perhaps right and and the american
experiment and the american ideal that
people have to have access to actual
information and the only way for them to
do it by the way i'm a 501c3 of the
economics of project veritas you're
right people talk about how the money we
raise we have 100 000 donors that give
us this money i started with nothing i
mean
they were saying i was funded by right
being billionaires when i literally was
broke and and destitute on my credit
where were you did you ever
so i was so broke with that acorn store
i took the chesapeake bay bridge because
it was four dollars less people thought
i was nuts yeah so they project what
it's all about so the story about koch
brothers that's a lie that they never
participate in helping you out with uh
project veritas we don't disclose our
donors i mean for all you know hillary
clinton is funding us it doesn't matter
well that would change the story that
now you've got babylon bees got a story
tonight
but it wouldn't change the story because
the re the things that we're presenting
are real
and and upton sinclair you know people
forget that like you know nelly bly and
sinclair and lincoln stevens they're all
socialist and you know what more power
to them if you have an agenda like this
but what you what you shouldn't do
is you shouldn't deliberately mislead
and give a false impression to your
viewers it's not as much the motive or
or your political agenda yeah it's that
you tell a deliberate untruth to people
it doesn't matter who's funding you it
matters whether you're deliberately
telling an untruth
yeah so for example like this story the
the forbes story that was written
november 11 2011 which was a couple
months you've read this article you're a
guy that follows the stuff
1.9 million since 2011 okay that's what
that's 10 years 11 years i don't care
how much money you're getting paid for
that so you made four hundred thousand
dollars last year after you live in what
state by the way you live uh west
chester new york okay so you're broke
this is what it is i'm serious with you
if you're making 400 grand you're in new
york
you got 200 left to yourself well here's
an interesting thing about economics
because i think it's a fascinating
question we're a full philanthropic news
organization now you know they're a
billionaire uh chairman of media
companies we've settled lawsuits we've
never settled the lawsuits it'll cost me
two million dollars to get the jury
verdict in the court case two million
i could have we could have given to
someone fifty thousand dollars and
settle the lawsuit
why would we not do that well if you're
a businessman if you're if you're if
your imperative is cash money if you
wanna keep money in your pocket you're a
masochist if you look at this and say i
could spend 50 000 to make the lawsuit
go away or i could spend 2 million go
through discovery go to trial and i
might lose yeah and we've never
settled a case and that's why our legal
bills at veritas are
some years five million dollars a year
five million and all proceeds from this
book goes to our organization to pay our
reporters salaries but the economics of
of journalism there's no business model
for investigative reporting
it's self-evident um all of the
corporations have slashed their
investigative bureaus because it's too
expensive
it's it's too painful and that's why our
our model is the 501c3 the non-profit
philanthropic model i mean the story
continues to say well mother jones
liberal magazines pays its president
only 225
and they generated 16.6 million the
daily caller news foundation which
publishes conservative content online
pays their chief development officer 138
can they keep going with all these other
stories judicial watch another
right-leaning crew pays its treasurer
395 000 and they go probably anyways
they're telling all these stories here's
here's kind of where where i'm going
with this uh part here so if somebody
from your own organization went out
there and said listen
i work for james the other day he
offended me because he made a joke that
really upset me he made a comment about
the chiefs losing and how excited he was
and how dare you say anything about pat
homes right i have access to all the
people that give here's a list i give it
up you wouldn't care you'll be like okay
that's part of the whistleblower game
which which list the the uh whoever the
the donors are to you that i would part
of that i wrote a whole chapter in this
book about this and i'm and i'm writing
a a book about journalism ethics i'm
writing a manual because no one has
really ever done this before so i'm
trying to define
the boundaries and this is a very
critical point there are only two things
we keep secret
because really because really
underlying your your line of questioning
here is this notion of hypocrisy like
james o'keefe you probably you're he's
your cross to bear you probably do
things in private and my answer is
listen
i we all make mistakes we're all human
but there are two things that so help me
god i will not disclose because it is
enshrined
in the fundamental values that we hold
as americans which is number one the
rights to protect our sources
and the right to protect our donors by
the way if the united states supreme
court were to order
me
to reveal who released that document
from the pentagon i would be held in
contempt of court and go to jail to
protect my source this i would i would
anderson uh the legendary muckraker from
the 1970s i would i would submit to your
honor that you're an error
and i would not i would not oblige with
that and i would and i would this is i
would be
i would i would have to face
incarceration in perpetuity rather than
disclose my source this is this is
enshrined in
the dna of the first amendment you don't
disclose your source and you don't
disclose if the naacp to borrow an
analogy
in 1958 were ordered by the supreme
court to disclose who donates to the uh
you know an organization that protects
the rights of african americans that was
that's what that case was about so when
you when you ask me well what if they
published your information i'm sorry but
so help me god there are two things i
will never disclose and i cannot
disclose oh by the way because to do so
would be anathema to the very to the
very things that give us the first
amendment in the first place okay
so no no no donor has ever been um of
course the people that are trying to
disclose these donors don't share
a
faith
in these principles they don't like the
first amendment and and and that's the
only public policy issue that i take a
stance on anything else i don't really
have a
political views but on this
on this
here i stand i can do no other and
that's why i wrote that chapter called
secrecy because i meditated on this and
i realized
everything else i have to have
disclosure on
and by the way we do file a tax return
and we put it on our website do you know
any other news organization that does
that no we do we we publish that 990 we
we disclose everything we go through
discovery and litigation i've been
deposed more times i can count by the
way i like depositions i have a good
time being deposed you know why because
i got nothing to hide you know who
doesn't like being deposed the new york
times
they're scared of that you know why
because they have everything to hide and
that's the difference really that's the
difference between project veritas and
anyone else so on those two things i i
would never want to disclose them and i
will fight to the death to not disclose
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you